singer brandy Norwood reportedly fell  unconscious on a Delta flight shortly  before takeoff  she was set to fly from Los Angeles to  New York City on Friday morning when the  incident occurred a spokesperson for the  LA City Fire Department tells ET that  they responded to an incident at 6:17  a.m. at LAX regarding an unspecified  medical complaint and an ambulance  transported someone from the airport to  the hospital officials could not confirm  any patients names or the hospital where  they were taken Delta confirmed to ET  that flight 763 returned to the gate  after a customer fell ill on board and  departed 45 minutes behind schedule  according to TMZ brandy was removed from  a plane after an airline employee  contacted paramedics and the LA Fire  Department the site reports brandy did  regain consciousness while being treated  on the jetway  and was taken to the hospital ET has  reached out to Brandy's rep for further  details  [Music]